♪ ♪
Morning.
- Ron.
- Good morning, Mr. Sheltie.
How's the fam?
Oh, I don't--I don't have--
I'm single, sir.
I'm not married.
I mean, I do have a girlfriend.
That's great.
[coughs]
Oh, God!
[slaps hands]
Hey, I need you
to do me a favor.
Make sure everybody knows
that the bagels are
for sales associates only.
No problem, sir.
All right, let's get
this sales presentation started.
[laughs nervously]
All right, who's hungover?
[laughter]
Not me.
I know Ron is.
That's not true.
You're an alcoholic.
[laughter]
I'm not, sir, I'm not.
♪ ♪
Hey, guys,
sales associates, friends.
Today I want to talk about...
the world's oldest profession.
[laughs]
Now hold on, hold on!
I know, I know
what you're thinking, right?
Sex and prostitutes.
That's not
what I'm talking about.
Okay?
I'm talking about sales.
And if you look at our
ancient history as human beings,
the first caveman out there...
[ominous music]
♪ ♪
Oh, I'm sorry, those are
for sales associates only.
It's food.
N-not for you,
I'm sorry.
Bagels are just
for sales associates.
For sale?
No, it's free.
Oh, for free?
Not--not for you, though.
It's just for me?
No, the--
To divide ourselves...
The bagels are
only for sales associates.
Ron.
Love the enthusiasm,
but it's a little distracting.
[laughter]
I'm sorry.
I'm sorry, sir.
Oh, don't do it again, please.
Sorry.
(Sheltie)
Moving on...
For me maybe?
No, not--not maybe.
I'm sorry,
I'm so sorry.
Foss?
Foss--what?
For us?
No, no, not for us.
One, just one.
It's just that they're
for sales associates only.
For me maybe?
♪ ♪
- Forget--
- Okay, Ron!
Yep.
Just shut up.
[chuckles]
All right, what was
the first tongue twister
you remember hearing?
Was it "she shells"--
[laughs]
- Sir, no, sir.
- Was it--was it "she sells"--
Cream cheese is also
only for sales associates.
How come
it's not for me, why?
Because the bagels
are for sales--
- Ron.
- Yes.
Time and place, man.
I'm sorry, this guy
just keeps trying
to grab a bagel, and--
Ron, do you want
to come up here
and do the presentation?
I'll go back there
and be a jackass?
You just asked me to make sure
that nobody but--
"Oh, the sign says--
my name's Ron.
I like to drink alcohol
and listen to signs all day."
He's really relentless
about having a bagel.
- And I tol--
- Ron, handle your bagels!
I'm trying.
Unbelievable, everybody.
All right, I'll just--
I'll start cold.
Cells make up our bodies,
but selling makes our bodies
come alive.
[sniffing]
(Ron)
Sir, seriously, stop.
Not even smell?
No, no, no!
You can't have any bagels!
You can't have any cream cheese!
And you can't have smells!
That's what
the fucking sign says!
- Ron!
- Yes!
You are fired, sir!
Of course I am!
[sighs]
All right, you know what?
Just give me a minute.
I'm gonna try to forget
Ron ruined my day,
'cause this presentation
is great,
and it's going great.
I'm gonna get a bagel.
These bagels...
Bagels are
for sales associates.
He's right, Ron.